i want to play this for you also now
this is another one
i feel like this in this in this episode
the people watching it on video are
experiencing some privilege because
there's been a few a few different
things that don't translate as well to
audio but i've got to play this because
it's just it's too good
um michelle wu who's the mayor of boston
decided to do a little instagram live
session a couple of days ago
and uh
that's always risky
you know because you're live on the air
and you're you're opening yourself up to
questions
and you don't know what questions are
going to be asked
um
we do this so we have all access live
here if you become a daily wired member
you get you get access to all access
life and where we sit down and we're
live and we're just answering any
questions that come up right
so this is what she did only a little
bit of a riskier proposition because
she's on on instagram
and she's sitting there
um i guess expecting that there'd be a
whole bunch of
softball questions
that's not how it turned out so just
let's play some of this and we'll so
here she is go ahead and play this
um
oh since she's unable to
okay join she's sitting there
looking extremely awkward and you can
see in her eyes the panic setting in and
she's trying her best but every single
question is you're ruining the city in
the meantime i will
[Music]
any questions anyone has
to answer any questions anyone has but
she's not answering any of the questions
a lot of
friends who uh
have different oh happy new year yes
year of the tiger very very cute all the
other questions are you're ruining the
city you're horrible and the masked
mandates when will you lift the mandates
that's actually a fair question she
could answer that
okay when will you lift it we're
checking with the congresswoman's team
and if
it comes down to it i will log out and
log back in unmask our kids doesn't want
to answer that
[Music]
you almost feel sorry for it
almost almost watching this
end the mandates recall her just every
single comment
why don't you care about your people
fair question fair question
see now she's just sitting there she's
giving up
she's looking for her way out what's my
favorite thing about boston winter um
i
i
i love snow i know
here's what this is why i wanted to play
that entire thing
because she sits down
for instagram live assuming that the
internet will be nice to her and that's
mistake number one
never assume that
the internet will be nice to you
especially when you are a
an incompetent tyrannical mayor who's
ruined your city
you definitely don't want to assume it
then um but she thinks you can get a
bunch of softball questions she doesn't
and so all the questions are why are you
ruining the city what you're doing is
horrible when will you lift the mandates
all the comments and questions are fair
but of course she doesn't want to engage
with any of those
and then at the very end she finally
gets
a softball question the kind that she
was hoping to get
which is what's your favorite thing
about winter
because by the way you know that when
this started
and it was going the wrong way
they they were scrambling on the other
side they were getting staffers on
instagram live to throw out the
softballs
and so one of the staffers they're in
the next room and they type out the
softball question what's your favorite
thing about winter mayor
and she can't even answer that even that
she can't answer it you're the mayor of
boston
and someone says what's your favorite
thing about winter um
uh do
i like the snow
even that was too hard for her
i swear that the most unimpressive
people in the country become politicians
the most unimpressive
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated